[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
make sure this works
all right great hi this is a picture of
astronaut Peggy Whitson
she's on a spacewalk outside the
International Space Station imagine
floating out there in space you look
down at the earth it's a hundred miles
below you you're feeling so small and
insignificant looking out at the
vastness of space around you and to
fight despite feeling so small you might
feel comforted knowing that you have the
support of an incredible team scientists
at NASA who are using the latest and
technology to plan this mission for you
to use data and models to let you do
your job as effectively and as safely as
possible or so you'd hope this is miles
Solomon a seventeen year old from Great
Britain who was looking through some of
the data that NASA makes publicly
available he noticed some abnormalities
Miles was looking at radiation sensor
data radiation sensors like one that
he's holding in his hand those sensors
are located on the space station and
they record different levels of
radiation in the environment when they
detect some radiation they log a
positive value indicating that severity
and when no radiation is detected they
should be reporting a zero value but
instead what Miles found was that these
sensors were recording negative numbers
this is potentially a very big deal we
don't know exactly how this data was
being used but you can imagine there's a
model somewhere that's taking this data
into account to assess the safety of a
potential space mission without being
able to account for the negative
readings that we have in this data we
might think that there's less radiation
out there than there actually is looking
at this data you might make the decision
to have a go on a space walk instead of
a no-go that could be pretty dangerous
this is a case where data really can
mean the difference between life and
death the really crazy thing about the
story is that the domain
experts here the scientists at NASA did
think that these negative readings were
possible they didn't think that they
would happen that often though not
enough to make a difference maybe once a
year what miles was showing was that
this was clearly happening far
frequently once a year and if they had
just put some data quality checks in if
they were understanding their data a
little bit better it would have saved
them a little bit of embarrassment
by having a 17-year old called them out
on some of their data some of us here
may be looking at scientific data others
at product data or financial data or
software data but data quality and
understanding data shift and something
is important to all of us so today I
hope you can come away with some
consideration for thinking about data
quality and anomaly detection first and
foremost when you design data pipelines
and when you're starting to consume data
unfortunately I won't have enough time
to get into many details about specific
statistical techniques that we're using
or the technology implementations that
we have the goal is to keep this talk
pretty high level and and concepts that
you can take away and bring back to your
organization but I'd be happy to get
into more details later so please come
find me or one of my Netflix colleagues
at our office hours which will be after
the launch let's talk about some the
data that Netflix looks at we have a
hundred million members we just crossed
this threshold it's very exciting for us
but we still have a long way to go but
those 100 million members live in
countries all around the world and they
collectively stream over a hundred and
twenty five million hours of content
every day that's a lot of watching
Netflix that's really benjin right there
if we if we did a little bit of math
back of the math envelope here and we
assume that an hour of Netflix content
in high definition high quality is about
three gigabytes of data multiply that
times your 125 million hours and we're
needing to deliver 375 petabytes of data
to our customers every single day
the data that's the equivalent of
something like 80 million DVDs chock
full of storage it's a lot of
information you might wonder how do we
deliver 375 petabytes of data every day
without breaking the internet and here's
the answer
this is a server that Netflix has
developed it's custom built to hold all
of the video files the audio files the
subtitles everything that you as a
customer need to stream Netflix we take
these servers and we distribute them all
around the world to make them as close
to our customers as possible there's one
sitting and a data center in your city
there's one maybe sitting inside your
ISP your internet service providers own
internal network the goal of this
localization is that when our customers
need to stream all that data it doesn't
have to travel very far to get to them
which means that that we actually get to
deliver a really high performance
Netflix experience every single time a
great thing about these servers in
addition to allowing us to very
efficiently stream Netflix is that they
give us a lot of data so it makes our
data teams very happy what's actually
happening when you stream Netflix is
that you've loaded up your device a
little hard to see but you have a device
and you've browser on in the UI you
found something that you want to watch
and you click play your device sends a
request to one of these servers asking
for a piece of content the device of the
server says ok that checks out we can
watch this piece of content let me send
some of that data back to you the first
chunk of that particular video your
device or CSI data data it's decoding it
it's rendering it and your UI on your
screen and playing back and you're
asking for a little bit more data the
next piece of that video so on and so
forth the server sends that data back
and we're doing this all in real time so
that we can adapt to various network
conditions that your device is
experiencing that's what the product
experienced in real time on the data
side we're collecting a lot of
information about what's going on both
from the device perspective and the
server perspective from the device we're
understanding what is that customer
variants really like who are you as a
customer what device are you streaming
on how quickly did it take that video to
load did you experience any errors or
interruptions during the course of that
playback and from the server side we're
capturing information about that same
series of transactions but thinking
about it from the server's own
perspective what is P was I connected to
to deliver that content how many bytes
did I transfer in each connection how
long did it take those bytes to arrive
at their destination was the latency all
of these raw logs are landing in Amazon
s3 which we use as our main storage
system and my team comes in and is using
some business logic and windowing and
some sophisticated tooling to process
all this data merge it together and at
the end of the day we create a data set
that combines the perspective of the
customer experience with the network
experience this is a really critical
data set at Netflix because it's the
only place you can go to to understand
how the network experience really
affects what our customers are seeing
when they stream Netflix this is you
know just go my famous slide here with a
picture of what's in this data looks
like don't read too much into it but the
point is it's got a lot of different
types of data that we're looking at we
have metrics we have dimensions this is
just a tenth of the columns that we look
at and we're writing out over well over
a billion records every single day so as
I mentioned this is a very core data set
for Netflix and we've stood this up
recently and we're now in the process of
instilling a bunch of data quality and
anomaly detection checks on this data
set there are four main considerations
that I have when we do these checks and
so I walk through them one by one and
what we'll kind of cover them as we go
along the first is the impact I
mentioned this is a very important table
for us and so it makes sense for us to
invest into making sure the data is of
high quality
and that we understand how it changes
over time
any data that really should have a bare
minimum of data checks in place but this
is one that's being used by many
different people and we're making pre
important decisions with it so it's
actually worth a little bit more
investment above and beyond what the
bare minimum is we're making decisions
like which partnerships might we want to
invest in which is peas or which devices
could bring valuable partnerships to
Netflix or where should we invest our
internal engineering resources where do
we have the most performance problems
and then we need to let make sure that
our software engineers are addressing
this problem next is data integrity I
described two sources of data that we
deal with the devices and the servers
but in reality there's actually six data
sources we use in the state of pipeline
that means that there are six places
where things can go wrong when I talk
about data integrity here's an example
of what I mean it's really thinking
about the source inputs into whatever
your ETL pipeline is where this can go
wrong is if you've got missing data for
maybe you've got a hive table with some
partitions and the partitions don't
exist or they don't have data in them
maybe you have some unexpected data
types flowing through nulls when there
shouldn't be perhaps you have some
malformed records that mean that you
can't parse out key value pairs that you
want to parse out we found it's best to
be able to detect these types of data
integrity issues during or even before
your ETL processing we do this before by
looking at metadata about our source
input tables so we have a we luckily at
Netflix we have amenity of a service
that gives us information about our
hives metadata we can say is that
partition loaded how many rows are there
is there what's the min and Max values
that exist within that column what's the
cardinality of that column and if we
have suspicions that things aren't quite
right here then we can choose to do
something about whether we want to
process that data or not we also want to
make sure we quantify what's happening
during our ETL processing so there's
business logic that tells us we should
throw away some
percentage of data that we're reading
and it's just not relevant for the
output data set so we want to quantify
how much we throw away though that if
that's 5% one run and it goes to 50% the
next time then it may not even indicate
a big problem but it's something we want
to be able to know an alert on once you
have those checks in place you get to
decide what to do with them if that's if
the case i just described is happening
where you're you're throwing away a lot
more data
maybe you're comfortable continuing to
process it and release that data for
downstream consumption but maybe you're
not it's going to depend on your use
case if your source data is totally
missing then yeah don't even start that
utl process lastly these are really
shouldn't say easy but these are
problems that can be addressed with
reusable frameworks virtually any
pipeline needs that kind of data
integrity check on your source data so
we can try to make this reusable and
extensible at Netflix we are working
between our data engineering teams and
our data platform teams to make sure
that we can address these data quality
questions on source table every time you
write out data you can audit it before
you even publish it to be available for
downstream consumption and that's going
to go a long way to letting us be sure
that the tables that we're ingesting for
our source data are completely fine in
terms of the main metadata about them to
allow us to focus more time on
addressing business metric issues that
require a little bit more domain
knowledge and those are a little bit
more complicated let's talk about them
the business metrics next this pipeline
has dozens of metrics that we care about
looking at and dozens of dimensions you
think about the thousands of devices
that Netflix customers are streaming on
that the thousands of ISPs that they're
connected to we operate in almost 200
countries there's just many dimensions
and they have high cardinality so it
makes it a challenge to figure out where
things are changing when there's so many
permutations and this is where anomaly
detection really starts to shine
when I talk about business metric shifts
I think about things like in our world
we look at error rates we don't want to
make sure that we know when those are
changing we also might want to know when
our customers consumption of Netflix is
changing in some way this is a really
interesting one because you may see a
shift a very sudden spike it's very
visible in terms of how people are
changing consumption but there also
might be a longer-term shift that you're
going to want to detect and that might
require different types of algorithms
and a different approach another one
that comes up pretty frequently is a
metric shift that's caused by a change
in logging we have a lot of normalized
or ratioed metrics the percentage of
playback sessions that experience some
types of event and often they change not
because there's actually a change in the
customer experience but because some
logging issue has happened where the
numerator or the denominator has been
impacted we want to we definitely wanna
make sure we catch those what let's walk
through an example so let's say this is
a global playback error rate the
percentage of sessions that end in a
fatal error for our customers it's not
so don't we into the data but just for
example this is this is a key metric
that our executive team does track so
you want to make sure that we we have
our eyes on this and let's say that this
spike is actually being caused only by
Android phones in the country of Brazil
they're having some some crazy issue we
want to be able to know that because as
the owners of this data is the stewards
of this metric in this pipeline we want
to be the ones who can talk about it and
describe it and annotate it before the
CEO comes knocking on our door so first
we need to identify what change we need
to know that it was the Android phones
in Brazil that are causing this problem
we're taking a very simple approach I
mentioned we're standing this up right
now so it's still in early days but we
can do this by pre aggregating data to
various grains that we think are
meaningful in our case devices and
countries are very common dimensions
across which our metrics use shift so we
define that as a level of aggregation to
run anomaly detection on we're using a
JSON config to describe what dimensions
and metrics to pre-compute and pass over
to our knowledge section service we'd
say give me a time series give me days
and hours and device types and countries
to be able to pass over to that service
run our Nelly detection algorithms on
and receive that time series back with
annotated data points on which seem
anomalous this is very simplistic I will
absolutely admit that we a much better
solution would be to be able to
automatically detect the places where
these these problems are occurring we
can't pre aggregate to every single
potential roll-up and that's just really
not not scalable it's really at the end
of the day a dimensionality reduction
problem we think we can get there and be
a little bit smarter but we're going to
start small next up is defining our
sensitivity around alerting we could go
crazy with being very sensitive to any
type of metric shift but that's probably
not going to be very meaningful to us so
I do think we're making the right choice
by starting pretty conservatively here
pick the top metrics that you care about
and you want to know have changed and
make sure you're just alerting on those
to the right people and you can scale it
up and tune over time so we know what
happened and we know we want to our load
on it how do we do that alerting we've
chosen to use emails for this emails are
great at Netflix because they're very
push they're not pull you get something
in your inbox that tells you there's an
action you need to take there's an
investigation you need to perform and
that's much better we get more response
than if someone has to go to a pull
mechanism to go to say and anomaly
dashboard and figure out what's
meaningful for them so we really like
the emails here and we think about
providing context here as well I firmly
believe that a picture is worth a
thousand words which is ironic because
there's no picture on this slide but I
mean a week we could absolutely include
a link to this change in the error rate
with the
red phones in Brazil and we also one
provide a link to an interactive
dashboard that lets a human being be
able to explore this problem a little
bit more maybe the first question you're
going to say I have after you see this
problem is that it is are there other
devices that are impacted in the same
country but maybe to a lesser extent or
is there a cyclical problem with Android
that's actually just now going out of
bounds and we're finally capturing it
and then finally personalization is key
as well this takes a little bit more
work because it involves figuring out
who cares about what and managing Google
Groups or distribution lists but it's
very possible and actually I think
there's a long way to making sure that
you're not being too aggressive or
spammy with your alerting you know we've
got a p.m. for Brazil and a p.m. for
Android those are the going to be the
people that have the most context about
what's going on to potentially cause
these issues and they're going to be
ones who are most invested in actually
helping us solve them that's going to go
a long way to make sure that the right
people know about different types of
problems and finally scales this is this
is a fun one to Netflix scale is a
couple of different things in my mind
it's really the scale of the data that
we're processing here but it's also the
way we scale our anomaly detection
framework I mentioned that this data set
has well over a billion and a half or
something like a billion and half
records every day and that means that
it's a lot of data to process and in our
current trades were doing that pre
aggregation of data if we had to do that
in a MapReduce environment that those
pre aggregations would take a really
long time if we want to do that on 40
different roll-ups for example that's
that's not really going to scale very
well it's going to take up a lot of
cluster resources luckily for us we've
chosen to take our data outside of hive
and put a recent copy of it into
elasticsearch for visualization purposes
that's been a very successful technology
at Netflix and the great thing is there
we have an indexed data store and so we
can very quickly query that data back
for all of our pre aggregation
and pass it along to our nomally
detection service another technology
that we found great at Netflix has been
druid an Olaf datastore with similar
response plans and note that this is all
related to a batch print processing
framework in a daily or hourly batch if
you're doing stream processing and you
want to run an anomaly detection you're
going to have some slightly different
technology considerations how do we
scale the anomaly detection framework
itself I've been describing this as a
service that we call so you know there
it sounds somewhat magical but we take a
time series of data we pass it along to
the service we're doing data transfer
across a network and then getting that
data back and that's that's really not
terribly efficient we want to be able to
have a service at scale so this the same
core set of algorithms actually exists
as a library as well that we can VOC in
our code to run in the same
infrastructure where the data actually
resides so that's one way to scale at
Netflix we talk about a shared anomaly
detection framework and that also means
that you're going to want more people to
use it more people to contribute to it
which contributes to a scale problem one
of the most interesting things we've
done is make the scalability work in
terms of contribution and evaluation of
algorithms we make it very easy for
anyone to contribute a new algorithm to
our code base and also to evaluate its
performance so if I'm contributing some
new algorithms that we don't already
have I can take a particular data set
run my knowledge section on that data
set and see how it performs against all
the existing algorithms which is great
for a contributor but also for a
developer if I have a data set and I
don't exactly know which kind of
algorithm I should use should be
interquartile range should it look at 3
Sigma deviation are those going to be
sufficient or maybe I should go to
something more complex like DB scan or
robust anomaly detection this type of
evaluation framework that's automated
helps me get there
okay so we talked about the four
considerations there and in conclusion
do you guys cool minutes over lunch I
think we can all be a little bit more
like miles data quality and anomaly
detection should be some of the first
things that we think about when we
design data pipelines when we consume
data not an afterthought it's not
something that we should think about as
adding when we have some spare cycles
because we all know that that free time
very rarely comes along using our domain
expertise as the folks who care most
about the data or working with the
business users who use it in those is
really critical to we want to make sure
that we're alerting on the right kinds
of metrics and to the right levels so
not too little and not too much what's
going to be best for the entire
organization and lastly it's great to
think about how to scale these
frameworks because these types of
problems do not exist in isolation we
should not try to solve them in
isolation developing a great practice in
your data organization around sharing
different problems and solutions and
frameworks for data quality will go a
long way and your entire data where it
can build a culture and muscle around
data discipline as the data folks here
as the analytics folks and the data
engineers data credibility and data
expertise are some of the most valuable
assets that we bring to our
organizations providing high quality
data and proactively delivering alerts
and insights around how that data
changes are really really great
opportunities for us to seize and the
good news is that they are absolutely
achievable if we just make them a
priority that's it
[Applause]
give this mic
great I think you look great
presentation whatever one of the things
you talked about were six approaches
about data integrity and one of them was
in a possible null instances in your
JSON how tolerant you are when some of
the fields are no because if you are
actually getting data at a regular
intervals as possible as some of the
filter no do you keep track of how many
nodes you've actually seen in data and
then you can check it out or we can say
no after n number of nulls of this
particular imperative data I'm going to
stop processing how do you how do you
actually deal with those it's certainly
not a problem you know if you have null
values come in and you shouldn't you
want to be able to tell that at the very
least we use smart counters in most sort
of pipelines to be able to at least
quantify what it is that we're missing
and the decision on what to do with that
is going to depend you know there are
some places where if that's a really
critical field you you may not even want
it you want to stop right there in other
cases you may be a little bit more
lenient it's going to really depend on
how that data is being used and so it's
going to be a little bit of a judgment
call but certainly being able to
quantify that in any field or type of
structure that you're processing is is
really key so it's kind of curious on
when you're talking about anomalies in
changes in viewing patterns one of the
things that is always a challenge it
seems to be is taking into account time
of day day of week and those kind of
things is that something that you guys
have to build into the algorithms to
check for anomalies or how do you handle
that
if seasonality is a big one and we
certainly have you know seasonal
patterns of viewing or really any
metrics contend to have some type of
patterns that you see periodically so a
lot of algorithms are actually pretty
well designed to address size link hold
learners is one where you get to kind of
observe that seasonal pattern and learn
from it and the data the robust anomaly
detection framework that is open sourced
by Netflix actually takes into account
weekly seasonal patterns is how it was
developed so it is it's really important
to think about what that data looks like
should be able to figure out what you
want to think is an anomaly because if
you just had a very simple kind of
detection then you know your weekly
spike might look like something that's
more problematic but there are the great
the great news is there are algorithms
that can help you address that but it
also takes a little bit of domain
knowledge about what that data is
looking like so for an organization that
runs I presume like problems of a/b
tests I'd imagine there are like sort of
intended anomalies right so is there you
know these are things that are intended
viewing pattern changes like how do you
there are human loop to the extent so
you know that you know this is a new
really expected that you know really
thinking about across dozens of a/b
tests it's a good question oh certainly
we're changing our products and testing
it to see what's better for our
customers and trying to roll those
changes out and a lot of times we'll see
impacts from testing actually not
because they're so large-scale but
really more on the logging side so that
that new version we wanted to spin up
for a different product experience it
you know we didn't think about making
sure the logging was coming through
correctly so there's a lot of time that
we need to spend to make sure the
logging is there to be able to even do
that evaluation and sometimes we'll see
that come through in higher order
metrics it's that's where it's really
critical to have that context around
what's changing and making sure we can
loop in the right people like maybe that
personalization process can involve the
a/b testing team who kind of says oh
yeah sorry we pushed a change that's
what's causing your spike in your
metrics but there and there there's
always be some amount of noise and the
data due to those types of
experiences that we're testing how much
of this framework is open-source or how
much is it shared with you know the
larger community
they were busting Amelie detection
framework is different source if you
google for it rad you'll find it on our
tech blog that was originally written in
pig so it you know it might be useful
for anyone who's using that language the
the framework that we're developing with
our data infrastructure team around
making sure that source data is not
making sure it's clean before it's
released to be consumed is something
that's actually under active development
right now and I'm not sure if we're
playing to open source that or not but I
can check with them are a great talk so
another question have you get played
with streaming algorithms like sketching
hyper log-log stuff like that I'm
probably not the best person to talk
about the streaming infrastructure
because I'm not using it but I know I
have some colleagues here who are so I
love them see to it or you can
compendious at the office hours sounds
good thanks
how big is the data team that built the
rad system rather than shrinks it
actually was collaboration with multiple
data teams at netflix
we have a data engineering and analytics
group something like 100 people that's
the state engineers data analysts I know
it's like a lot of people and so that's
one group who's working on kind of
making sure that that kind of framework
scales and applying it to the business
and it was a partnership with a science
and algorithms team so more of our data
science group who was working on the
exact algorithms to you know figure out
that seasonality and how to handle it so
at a nice little partnership there